these myths of threats they first
materialized on my earth many years ago
I was part of the last battalion life
trying to stop them all we did was delay
the inevitable the elementals are here
now attacking the same coordinates our
satellites confirm it we have one
mission kill it you're coming with us
it's a fury this all seems like big time
you know huge superhero kind of stuff
and I mean I'm just a friendly
neighborhood spider-man sir it's please
you've been to space Fury asked me to
come up here and see how you were doing
he just he felt bad about snapping at ya
really you guys do have sarcasm on this
earth right how you feeling I didn't
think I was gonna have to save the world
too sir
I know that makes me sound like such a
jerk I just I had this plan with this
girl that I really like him now it's all
ruined I like you Peter a good kid
there's a part of me that wants me to
tell you just turn around run away from
all this and then there's another part
of me that knows what we're about to
fight what's at stake I'm glad you're
here
me too but you're worried about your
friends yeah
just always feel like I'm putting them
in danger look just get him inside and
keep them in a safe place for just a few
hours and they'll be alright it's really
nice to have somebody to talk to you
about superhero stuff you know any time
okay beat the rush here to rush out
lucky for us we got the best seats in
the house let's go
you look really pretty and therefore I
have value no no that's not what I meant
at all I was just I'm messing with you
thank you you're welcome
you look pretty too my glasses so cute
you want to go in on a pair you mean
that's it next to each other yeah no
okay
no wanna sit here you just don't I
didn't mean that if you go ahead I'll go
grab us a beer no I'm coming
what is going on these things destroyed
my world
snap to a hole in our dimension now this
threat is here
the worlds in chaos I need a new team
I need an Avenger what about the
offworld dr. strange unavailable chat
tomorrow don't invoke Rene
mr. stark trusted me
I'm not gonna let him down
we have to stop them
welcoming the Avengers
get gifts Parker
the world needs that
I've got this
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie we have a
whole bunch of spider-man far from home
trailers and scenes to break down
there's also a bunch of big Marvel news
that dropped this morning about
comic-con Marvel will be going they
confirm their panel I'll talk about that
at the end of the video Kevin Feige was
also talking about x-men characters
coming into the MCU so it's actually a
really big day for Marvel fans there's a
new round of that spider-man far from
home imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a spider-man comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this welcome to The Avengers Mysterio
I'm sure this totally won't go off the
rails what a great idea spider-man feels
like he's justified in minting a brand
new Avenger I guess because he's one of
the only ones around love the Doctor
Strange name-dropped - I'll explain that
there's actually a big theory about the
plot of the Doctor Strange movie that
involves spider-man far from home but we
start with the clip of Mysterio
explaining his backstory in much greater
detail about how the elementals
destroyed his world and he was the last
of a group of Heroes last of whatever
his world's version of the Avengers was
they tried to save it they were too late
you kind of see the metaphor they're
going for because this is happening
after the events of Avengers endgame
they want to make it seem like that was
a version of an earth where Thanos wound
up winning and destroying the entire
planet only it was just the elementals
that were causing all the damage and now
they're going to the same locations
where they destroyed that other world on
our earth then there's a scene of
Mysterio going to talk to Peter on the
bridge which seems like it's a little
bit later in the film after he's just
been chewed out by Nick Fury for
refusing the hero's call it sounds like
he spends a lot of the early part of the
film refusing that call or put a new
team together I'm sorry I'm busy I'm on
my summer vacation I have all this PTSD
from watching my surrogate father iron
man die in my arms just a couple months
ago the whole idea being that Mysterio
is supposed to be the cool uncle - iron
man's father figure giving spider-man
someone to talk to when he's all bummed
out about hero stuff that also
understands what he's going through so
one of his big arcs during the film is
dealing with the trauma and the grief of
losing Iron Man but his bummed out as he
seems in a lot of these scenes I don't
think that they're taking it to Tobey
Maguire levels of a Spider Man being
bummed out of all the live-action ones
at least he's probably been the most
bummed out of all the spider-man that
we've gotten so far
speaking of which there was actually
somebody during the press junkets
recently that asked Tom Holland if he
wanted to do a crossover
with Andrew Garfield spider-man in Tobey
Maguire spider-man a big multiverse
crossover of course he said yes any
chance there's a multiverse in which
Andrew Garfield spider-man until you
acquire spider-man and help your
spider-man all meet together clashing
but would you want that though would you
want that's it maybe that's a better
question what do we want that the thing
about this film that's so exciting right
is we take spider-man to Europe and
what's so cool about that you've never
seen spider-man in Europe before now of
course I'd love to make it would be
really really cool something the fans
really want so whether Marvel and Sony
decide to do that it's not up to me
I thought walking like Kevin this is
what we're doing on the next one yeah
but it would be then they go into the
scene of them at the Opera is just a bit
of a funny moment with Peter trying to
balance both of his lives trying to do
spider-man stuff with Nick Fury yelling
in his ear while they're in the middle
of a big tactical situation and also try
to make time with his lady MJ who's
still at this point in the film hasn't
figured out that he's spider-man but
clearly from the way they leave the
scene you can see that he's going to
have to ghost her during this
performance and she'll just wonder where
he went just like she did at the end of
the first film what are you hiding Peter
I'm just so they're just trying to
continue that idea that she's very
observant and she does kind of like
Peter so she pays attention to what he's
doing at all times and she just happens
to notice it he always seems to duck out
when really big things are happening so
that's part of the reason that Nick Fury
gives him the stealth suit during the
film so that other people also don't
start figuring out that he's spider-man
because he keeps popping up everywhere
these elementals pop up in spider-man as
well they keep showing the footage of
the old Avengers tower so I think it's
safe to say that at least one of the
post-credits scenes is going to be a big
reveal of who bought it from Iron Man
remember they would have to be crazy
rich so it's probably quote-unquote a
corporation I'm sure we're all here a
bunch of theories about that in the next
week or two there's a very big superhero
landing in the new Steve Ditko suit love
the new footage of that funny montage
scene of spider-man referencing all the
different characters including Doctor
Strange so they changed the line from
Captain Marvel as well to they'd
actually covered up the Doctor Strange
line maybe because when they first
released that clip
it was because it was right after
Avengers endgame came out of theaters
and they didn't want to completely give
away the Doctor Strange was coming back
but the new line is as Captain Marvel
don't invoke her name the big Doctor
Strange rumor though the reason why he
isn't available to help out during the
events of this movie is because it takes
place concurrently with the events of
Doctor Strange to which they haven't
started filming yet that movie is not
going to be released till like 2021 I
think
but during that movie Doctor Strange is
supposed to be trapped in the dream
dimension by the villain who is
nightmare this is the director talking
about that last year I really like the
character of nightmare and the concept
that the nightmare nightmare realm is a
dimension I always thought that was one
of the that's early that's like in the
first strange tale I think that's an
introductory EPS episode of Doctor
Strange and I always loved that then
spider-man infamously we should say
inducks Mysterio to the Avengers so of
course that's going to bite him in the
ass by the end of the movie but this
seems like it's pretty early with them
bonding spider-man grows really close to
him so that whatever big betrayal they
might have later in the film lands way
harder on spider-man there's a much
longer scene of him swinging through the
buildings in New York City probably
towards the end of the film I do like
the physics of this version of
spider-man in this movie I feel like the
gun much better at that since way back
in the Tobey Maguire era remember
Kirsten Dunst with the mannequin when
they would do those swinging scenes
sometimes her hair would blow the wrong
way it wouldn't quite make sense and if
you stare at it too long you can
definitely tell that she's holding on to
a mannequin and not an actual person
[Music]
we should still say even though some of
the special effects were a little more
primitive Spiderman tube remains one of
the best comic book films of all time
because all the Spiderman far from home
junkets are happening right now they're
interviewing all the people Kevin Feige
was doing interviews as well - he said
some funny stuff about Keanu Reeves just
because Keanu Reeves is on fire right
now the feeling of of being there of
walking the streets of the future is
really going to be breathtaking he said
that he's been talking to Keanu Reeves
on a regular basis ever since they've
been making Marvel movies looking for a
role for him but it's just taken this
long to find the appropriate one so
every time a new phase of films comes up
they always meet with Keanu Reeves to
try and talk about something that they
might be able to work on together the
new movie that he's supposed to be doing
right now is eternals that's the role
that he's up for but we don't know
exactly who he would be playing during
that do kaboom Canada's greatest
stuntman oh yeah yes he also said that
ever since the Fox deal completed and
they got access to all the x-men
characters at least on a legal level
they've been having regular meetings
with all the executives Marvel Studios
pitching ideas for x-men inside the MCU
whether it be their own solo films or
they do the spider-man Captain America
Civil War brown or like black panther
where they put them in a much bigger
film and then give them their own solo
film so even though it's gonna take a
long time for us to actually see some
x-men actually popping up inside Marvel
movies they're talking about it right
now but this is just like very early
pitch stage where people are trying to
come up with ideas why don't we
introduce Wolverine in the post-credits
scene for whatever movie is gonna be
right before the next Avengers film then
it becomes a much bigger character and
eventually joins the Avengers or why
don't we debut Professor X or Magneto or
Kitty Pryde then you can just theory
craft from there so obviously all that's
going on behind the scenes right now if
you're worried but he did say that
Deadpool is kind of its own separate
things so Deadpool isn't really being
considered for a big crossover movie
with an MCU character any time soon as I
making this video I'm still supposed to
go see spider-man far from home so my
non-spoilery early reaction review will
post tomorrow too as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
that video when I post it so no worries
it will be non spoilery we're not really
allowed to post really big review videos
till the end of the month
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video Caleb part
production company please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for that
brand new Avengers endgame deleted scene
with Iron Man and Doctor Strange and
then click here to learn about the
alternate ending to Avengers endgame
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]